2 doit se réunir à 15 heures je contrôle
15h30 donc au total une heure trente
d'horloge merci d'un d'orge
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je ne
trouve pas beaucoup plus longue que le
président buffet et salue tous nos
collègues participa à nos travaux en
visioconférence on va vous laisser
présenter en effet le le débat ou à
amorcer le débat monsieur le le ministre
pour ma part j'aurai ensuite une
question sur les tests
je vais vous avez la parole
monsieur le président la commission des
lois cher françois noël buffet madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales hr catherine de roche monsieur
le rapporteur philippe bas madame la
rapporteure pour avis chère chantal de
seine mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord laissez-moi on a
encore le droit de le faire vous
souhaiter une excellente année 2022 vous
remerciant de me permettre de m'exprimer
devant vous à l'heure où les débats
c'est vrai rejoigne le sénat qui nous
ont beaucoup occupé la semaine dernière
à l'assemblée nationale et qui porte sur
un nouveau projet de loi le 12e monsieur
le président le 12e qui a trait à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire un nombre
dont je ne peux m'empêcher de penser et
ce sera mon préambule qu'il reflète la
vitalité de notre système démocratique
puisque j'ai bien fait le tour avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues notamment
dans les pays de l'union européenne et
douze textes de loi c'est une
particularité française mais c'est une
particularité que nous assumons et qui
attestent d'ailleurs qu'en deux ans il a
fallu plusieurs fois remettre sur le
métier notre ouvrage
parce que les virus évoluent parce
qu'ils peuvent muter à tout moment on
l'a vu aux quatre coins du monde parce
qu'ils peuvent parfois nous laissait à
penser qu'on a trouvé la martingale qui
permettent de les freiner ou de les
faire disparaître et puis par moments se
rappelle à notre mauvais souvenirs à
travers des délétions sur le patrimoine
génétique viral qui le rendent ou plus
contagieux ou plus dangereux ou les deux
ou parfois plus contagieux et est moins
dangereux comme c'est le cas du variant
omicron mais il ya une constante c'est
que il ya une coordination qu'on voit
bien d'ailleurs au niveau international
et notamment au niveau européen qui
pousse vers des mesures je dirais qui
font partie d'un même panel un même
arsenal partout autour de nous ce sont
désormais les règles tu passes
sanitaires ou du pass vaccinale ou des
deux qui sont en vigueur certains pays
ont été amenés à prendre des mesures de
freinage plus ou moins importantes et
retentissante sur le quotidien des
français en france nous avons fait le
choix hormis la question du télétravail
et prévenante mais quitte absolument
indispensable de ne pas fermer des
établissements recevant du public de ne
pas fermer l plus tôt que prévu les bars
restaurants ou les établissements
recevant du public nous avons mis des
contraintes en matière de très grand
rassemblement parce qu'on veut limiter
le phénomène de super contamination
qu'une personne malade en contamine
mille autres parce que là ce serait
évidemment un très mauvais coup pour
l'épidémie en revanche nous avons laissé
ouvert tout un tas l'établissement qui
sont dans beaucoup de pays qui nous
entourent fermé je le dis encore une
fois en préambule
quelle est la situation épidémique
d'abord je le rappelle nous faisons face
à deux variants distincts il ya le
fameux variant delta que vous connaissez
bien qui est monté dans notre pays à la
faveur de la fin de l'été qui restaient
ensuite qui a fait une ascension assez
forte qui a impacté nos réanimation qui
a un impact toujours une réanimation de
plus en plus d'ailleurs chaque jour soit
2800 patients en réa désormais en france
et qui a atteint ensuite
un plafond qui est en même temps devenu
un plafond à ces fixe avec un nombre de
contaminations qui n'a pas diminué et sa
plateau merci pour le mot qui me
manquent et madame la sénatrice et donc
ce plateau nous a mis en difficulté
pendant plusieurs semaines parce que il
avait son lot de cas graves vairelles
deux variantes et le tight invariants
particulièrement invasif chez les
patients qui l'a qu'il contamine il
provoque des formes d'infection base
pulmonaire avec des syndromes de
détresse respiratoire comme on le
connaît désormais depuis deux ans et il
pousse un certain nombre de patients en
réanimation je le redis ces patients qui
sont en réhab pour le variant delta pour
des patients qui sont pour l'essentiel
des patients non vaccinés et pour celles
et ceux qui sont vaccinées ce sont des
patients qui sont immunodéprimées c'est
à dire que la vaccination n'est pas
assez efficace chez eux ce sont les
greffés du rein les greffés du coeur par
exemple ou des gens qui ont des très
grosses maladie comme des lymphome des
leucémies qui rend leur système
immunitaire inopérant
sur ce point de vue là et je suis très
prudent monsieur président madame la
présidente compte tenu à la fois de la
masse de tests réalisés au cours des
derniers jours on est à plus de 11
millions de tests sur une semaine ce qui
explose très largement tous les records
jamais enregistrée par notre pays
sans compter les autotests et du fait
des remontées avec les jours fériés et
c'est qu'il rend parfois les croisements
de données difficiles mais il semble
manifeste que désormais le variant delta
est amorcé une diminution qui était
attendu peut-être par un phénomène
d'ailleurs de compétition avec le
variant omicron qui est plus contagieux
probablement aussi du fait des mesures
même plus sûr plus certainement du fait
des mesures que nous avons mises en
place et notamment de télétravail jaurès
encore une fois prudents mais ce sera à
conforter dans les prochains jours ce
serait évidemment une nouvelle
rassurante pour nos réanimation d'ici 10
à 15 jours deuxième variante ces
variants omicron très contagieuse est
extrêmement contagieux on peut
l'attraper quand on est vaccinés on
amoindri de l'attraper mais on peut
l'attraper on peut le transmettre y
compris quand on est vacciné deux fois
moins nous disent les scientifiques que
si on est vaccinés mais on peut quand
même que si on n'est pas vacciné mais on
peut quand même le transmettre il donne
des formes qui sont des formes plutôt
hot que respiratoire c'est à dire ça
vous touche plutôt la région ici que la
région base pulmonaire dont qui donne
moins de détresse respiratoire donc ils
envoient moins les patients en
réanimation par contre il peut quand
même donné des syndromes fébriles à
s'est cognée des tous des des syndromes
grippaux à ses formes et il entraîne lui
une augmentation conséquente des
hospitalisations sur des sujets jour
dont nous voyons avec suffisamment de
recul désormais qu'ils sont
effectivement plus court que avec les
variants précédent les patients qui vont
à l'hôpital peuvent être jeune il ya
beaucoup de trentenaires dans les
hôpitaux qui sont atteints d'une forme
et autres non vaccinés je le redis et
qui vont avoir des besoins en oxygène de
3 4 jours et puis ensuite ils vont
pouvoir sortir donc on déploie
massivement un relais de l'hôpital à
domicile comme nous avons été capables
de le faire lors d'une vague précédente
c'est à dire de prendre en charge des
patients avec de l'oxygène à domicile en
lien avec leur médecin traitant les
infirmiers l'hospitalisation à domicile
de manière à réduire la pression sur nos
hôpitaux
et c'est pareil en micro vous l'avez vu
il a fait une poussée fulgurante il fait
une poussée fulgurante partout
je regardais la carte du monde le
burundi le canada les pays européens ça
a démarré cette fois ci en allemagne
avec un peu de délai mais ça a démarré
l'italie l'espagne tous les pays qui
avaient même ceux qui avaient été
épargnés plus ou moins par delta flambe
sous le sous l'effet dû aux microbes et
ça j'ai envie de vous dire quasiment
quelles que soient les mesures de
gestion de freinage qui ont été mises en
place on voit que ce variant il trace sa
course et ils évoluent très fortement
des montées à des trois cent mille cas
diagnostiqués dans notre pays ce sont
des chiffres hors proportion par rapport
à tout ce qu'on a connu depuis le début
de la pandémie et heureusement
heureusement un nous sommes très
vacciner et de ce variant il est moins
dangereux je le redis une fois que on
l'a on l'a attrapé la question qui se
pose c'est quand est-ce qu'il va arrêter
sa course folle
le modèle que nous suivons tous avec
attention au niveau européen on a une
grosse coordination là dessus ces
modèles anglais puisqu'il a démarré en
angleterre avant de démarrer en france
et je regardais que notamment dans la
région londonienne là où ils avaient
frappé en premier il baisse après avoir
une augmentation très très forte une
vague très vide qu'il a commencé à
baisser et de manière assez rapide ce
qu'on avait aussi constaté en afrique du
sud je ne peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui
qu'ils baissent dans notre pays ce
serait excessif de ma part et je me
garderai bien de faire un pronostic pour
les raisons évoquées un le nombre de
tests a explosé et donc ça peut modifier
évidemment les critères de comparaison
d'une semaine sur l'autre et de on a eu
toutes les remontées de données avec les
jours fériés et c'est donc nous verrons
dans les prochains jours si comme les
anglais nous atteignons un pic et
ensuite si ça entraîne une baisse ou si
ça fait comme delta un plateau ce qui
serait évidemment pas une heureuse
nouvelle donc je reste extrêmement
prudent de ce point de vue là et donc la
charge hospitalière on voit qu'elle
monte on a 21 mille malades aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux et je voulais dit nous
travaillons pour que les patients
puissent sortir plus tôt d'hôpital voilà
pour la partie la partie épidémiologique
pure sur la vaccination vous savez tout
53 millions de nos concitoyens ont reçu
au moins une injection nous avons battu
la semaine dernière leurs records de
primo injection depuis des mois deux
cent trente mille français ont fait le
choix de recourir la vaccination tant
mieux bienvenue à eux les nous battons
encore des records de prise de rendez
vous en vue d'une primo injection et je
le redis aux françaises et aux français
qui nous écoutent les centres de
vaccination vous accueilleront sans
rendez-vous si c'est pour votre première
injection c'est trop important on fait
évidemment attention à cela et nous
continuons dans la m dans le même
mouvement les rappels des rendez vous
ont été pris très non re pas
d'inquiétude sur les dates de rendez
vous il y avait trois millions de
rendez-vous disponible un peu partout en
france à la date de vendredi soir et
nous y arriverons les tests madame la
présidente je vais pas déflorer la
question vous allez me posais j'aurai le
plaisir d'y répondre c'est ce qui arrive
lorsque vous mourrez interrogé là-dessus
vous dire juste je ne peux pas passer
outre aussi ceux qui ce que vivent unsa
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens
depuis quelques jours maintenant
notamment dans le domaine des écoles
avec une politique de tests vous le
savez nous avons fait un choix et qui
est un choix qui est assumée de ne pas
fermer les écoles devaient fermer les
classes ou le moins possible ou
seulement quand on n'a pas la
possibilité de faire autrement et cela
va de pair oui avec une contrainte qui
peut être lourde pour ça un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes qui est de
réaliser des tests réguliers chez les
enfants lorsqu'ils sont qu'à contacter
pour éviter de les extraire de l'école
évidemment de travailler en temps réel
avec les scientifiques avec la
communauté enseignante jean michel
blanquer totalement mobilisé pour voir
s'il ya lieu d'adapter les choses ou de
simplifier la vie des français dans la
période que nous connaissons j'en viens
maintenant au projet de loi j'irai très
vite vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président il s'agit essentiellement de
la transformation du pass à lithaire en
passe vaccinale vous avez sans doute
suivi les débats à l'assemblée nationale
sur la question des mineurs il ya eu un
consensus à l'unanimité moins deux voix
qui a été trouvé pour n'appliquer le
pass vaccinale co 16 17 ans et de
maintenir le pass sanitaires pour les 12
15 ans pour les activités dites
périscolaires et extrascolaires tels que
activités culturelles et activités
sportives il ya eu des discussions
serrées sur la question du contrôle
d'identité nous avons eu déjà eu
l'occasion d'y d'y venir nous y
reviendrons dans les débats en séance
nous pensons que c'est important de
permettre à des personnes qui dirige un
établissement qui reçoit du public de
pouvoir n'ont pas contrôlé l'identité
mais vérifier la concordance entre
l'identité du pass et l'identité
figurant sur une pièce d'identité
haddock toutes ces questions là nous
nous en débattrons je rappelle que le
pass vaccinale ne s'appliquera pas pour
les établissements sanitaires et médico
sociaux c'était une évidence on va pas
empêcher les gens parfois j'ai des échos
de personnes qui me disent on l'a
empêché tel ou tel aller voir son père
qui est à l'hôpital qui est très malade
et ses jeunes il n'y a pas de directive
nationale visant à empêcher qui que ce
soit de visiter des proches qui seraient
malades fragiles ou encore moins en fin
de vie il en revanche des règles
sanitaires qui appelée qu'il faut les
visiteurs puissent attester du fait
qu'il n'en mèneront pas le virus à
l'intérieur de l'établissement pour ça
qu'ils aient cette dérogation de tests
qui est permise mais en définitive il
faut maintenir évidemment l'accès aux
personnes malades ou fragiles pour leur
entourage familial proche vous avez vu
aussi dans le projet de loi nous
renforçons les mesures qui permettent de
lutter contre les fraudes je les dis à
l'assemblée nationale on peut considérer
que le faux-pas sanitaire tu puisque
certains pourcentages de patients
hospitalisés disposer d'un faux pas
c'est à dire qu'il faisait croire à tort
qu'il était vaccinée ce qui entraîne des
conséquences sur la façon dont ces
patients seront soignés je les médecins
vous le diront ils savent que quand un
patient vient avec une forme qui
s'aggrave et qui est vacciné l'évolution
le pronostic est donc les critères de
surveillance d'intubation de mise en
commun ne sont pas les mêmes que quand
la personne n'est pas vaccinée quand on
n'est pas vacciné ça va plus vite
l'aggravation ça peut être même subi ça
peut se faire en quelques minutes et
donc il faut être en permanence en
surveillance étroite de ces patients là
enfin le projet de loi aborde des
questions qui n'ont pas de lien direct
avec le texte qui nous occupe c'est la
fameuse question de de lise allemand de
la contention secteurs de psychiatrie
nous voulons renforcer le rôle du juge
des détentions et libertés à la demande
du conseil constitutionnel et puis je
n'ai pas dit mais il ya évidemment vous
le savez le la déclaration d'état
d'urgence sanitaire la réunion en
martinique parce que la situation
sanitaire préoccupante justifie à nos
yeux le maintien des mesures de prêts
d'âge renforcée je vous remercie
rapidement monsieur le ministre
si vous pouvez clarifier la stratégie en
matière de tests parce que vont le
nombre de tests explose vous vous l'avez
dit la plupart sont remboursés à 100%
d'ailleurs j'aimerais savoir quel est le
coût actuel de cette politique de test
on le voit bien les pharmacies sursaturé
le système d'information a un peu de mal
à suivre avec trois cent mille cas
positifs par jour le contact racing
semble un peu un lointain souvenir et
les familles sont mises à rude épreuve
lorsqu'il faut tester les enfants trois
fois par semaine dans ces conditions
alors certes on empile des records si je
puis dire mais ça illustre un peu aussi
comment les ravages d'une auto
prescription remboursés à 100% et si
vous pouvez préciser là la stratégie
d'un mesure où le testing n'a de sens
que s'il est suivi de mesures cohérentes
quand on entend que des soignants soit
autorisé à continuer leur activité que
même si sur testé positif sinon s'ils
sont asymptomatiques
c'était ma remarque et emma question
monsieur rapporteur monsieur monsieur
bah
je vous remercie monsieur le président
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
et quelque chose d'un peu
paradoxal dans les débats de ces
derniers jours
c'est que on parle exclusivement
d'impasse vaccinale qui en réalité pour
la plupart des français déjà rentré dans
les moeurs puisque le pass sanitaires et
pour eux très majoritairement déjà
impasse vaccinale est par ailleurs face
à une flambée sans précédent de
l'épidémie
on ne peut pas dire que le pass
vaccinale souhaite une mesure
répondant à une urgence sanitaire
puisque il produira ses premiers effets
compte tenu des délais entre la première
injection et la deuxième injection
compte tenu de la date de promulgation
de la loi qui sera je l'espère
rapprocher au mieux à la fin à partir de
la fin du mois de février
et donc je me dis que nous sommes en
train de débattre d'un texte
auquel je ne fais ni excès la dignité ni
excès d'honneur
qui porte sur un sujet important
mais qui n'est en aucun cas l'alpha et
l'oméga de la politique sanitaire face à
l'irruption de cette nouvelle urgence
sanitaire
et puisque vous êtes oublié de nous
c'est plutôt sur ces questions là que je
voudrais vous interrogez en quoi ce
projet de loi répond t-il à cette
urgence sanitaire nous sommes nombreux à
penser que la vaccination est
essentielle
pour nous permettre sortir de l'épidémie
et des nombreuses vannes que nous avons
subies mais est ce que c'est un
instrument d'urgence sanitaire ma
réponse est plutôt de nommer peut-être
pourrez-vous la démentir
deuxièmement si on rentre dans les
détails le conseil scientifique vous a
alerté dès le mode décembre sur les
risques qu'il a qualifié de
désorganisation sociétale cette
désorganisation nous en voyons
maintenant les effets nous les voyons à
l'école nous les voyons à l'hôpital nous
les voyons dans le système de santé avec
les que pour faire les tests qui sont
souvent exigée pour les élèves que même
avec à l'allongement de la durée
d'attentes pour en avoir des résultats
avec une saturation des plateformes de
l'assurance maladie pour dire au cas
contacts ce qu'ils doivent faire
avec des craintes sur la disponibilité
des services hospitaliers mis à
l'épreuve par l'afflux des malades mais
aussi du fait que beaucoup de médecins
il semble qu'il y ait un consensus entre
eux sur le sujet disent qu'il ya jusqu'à
20 % des lits hospitaliers qui sont
actuellement fermés faute de personnel
s'agissant enfin de l'économie le
développement du télétravail a aussi ses
limites et donc au fond je voudrais que
vous nous disiez où on en est pour
l'école un protocole la veille pour le
lendemain à m'emmener au bout d'une
semaine la veille pour le lendemain
une lenteur dans la diffusion des
capteurs de co2
est ce que pour ce qui concerne
l'hôpital puisque je parlais à l'instant
de l'école on a déjà prévu la
mobilisation d'effectifs de secours
d'une réserve sanitaire
comment va-t-on s'organiser pour faire
face à un afflux de malades qui pour
l'instant n'est pas au niveau des
principaux pic nous avons connu mais
s'en rapproche
et donc on a beau dire
je crois en effet que les informations
que vous nous avez transmises sont
corroborés par la majorité des médecins
scientifiques épidémiologistes mais on a
beau dire que le variant au micron est
moins grave comme il n'y a plus de
personnes qui en sont affectés avec une
moindre proportion de cas graves on
atteint quand même des chiffres en
valeur absolue qui sont très élevés donc
voilà l'ensemble des questions que que
je voulais vous poser au fond ce qui est
en cause c'est l'ensemble de la
politique sanitaire face à l'épidémie
s'est pas simplement la transformation
d'un pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale dont nous
aurons bien sûr l'occasion amplement de
débattre ensemble cette semaine
madame de seine
merci monsieur le président mon
intervention sera dans la suite logique
de l'intervention de notre rapporteur
philippe bas au préalable je voudrais
rappeler que la commission des affaires
sociales a toujours pris ses
responsabilités
et qu'elle a toujours estimé lorsque les
circonstances l'exigent et que nous
devions faire front commun pour côté des
scientifiques et des médecins et si le
passionne thaksin a le pardon est jugé
efficace pour réduire l'épidémie et ses
conséquences nous le soutiendrons
cependant cette stratégie ne peut
réussir que si la campagne vaccinale
atteint réellement toute la population
cible donc ma première question est
simple comment résorber les inégalités
territoriales et sociales qui sont
encore visibles dans la vaccination des
français comment atteindre les non
vaccinés qui doute qui sont en marge des
systèmes de soins je pense en
particulier aux plus précaires aux
bénéficiaires des restos du coeur et
autres soupes populaires mais aussi aux
associations caritatives pour qui le
passent sanitaire actuellement ne
s'applique pas où est le fameux aller
vers temps promu et quel est votre
action spécifique à destination des
outre-mer où le faible taux de
vaccination
est mise en avant pour justifier leur
toit l'état d'urgence autre question le
port du masque en extérieur a été
suspendue dans le courant de l'année
2021 au motif d'une faible efficacité
scientifiquement constater quelles
données scientifiques justifie
aujourd'hui le retour du port du masque
en extérieur
dans le cas de la dérogation la
vaccination vaccinale après une
contamination
quelle durée et quel niveau de
protection les autorités sanitaires
reconnaît-elle
concernant les immunodéprimés
quelques fois et souvent malheureusement
le seul traitement la fin la seule
possibilité relève du traitement et non
de la vaccination où en est la recherche
et est ce que de nouveaux traitements
pourraient être autorisés en accès
précoce et puis je voudrais revenir sur
l'article 1er bis à qui crée un régime
de sanctions administratives applicables
aux employeurs qu'ils ne prendraient pas
les mesures de prévention nécessaires
pour limiter l'exposition au co vide je
suis assez réservé sur 7 sur des
nouvelles sanctions pour les entreprises
estimant qu'elles ont été très actives
et qu'elles ont mis en oeuvre les
mesures sanitaires qui s'imposait en
particulier le télétravail
donc même ma question comment pouvez
vous pouvez vous monsieur le ministre
nous indiquer précisément sur quels
critères se baserait l'inspection du
travail pour prononcer les sanctions
prévues et comment seraient appréciées
dans ce cadre des recommandations du
gouvernement sur le tri de télétravail
qui reste une recommandation au milieu
d'un certain nombre d'autres comme la
mise à disposition d'équipements de
protection pour les salariés je vous
remercie merci à ma porte a laissé la
parole à monsieur le ministre en
affirmant tout le monde qu'il y à déjà
aux collègues inscrits pour des
questions et que nous alternerons un
membre de la commission des lois avant
de la sphère sociale bien évidemment et
on fera par quatre et on essaiera de se
tenir dans le temps monsieur lui disais
à parler
répondre rapidement comme ça ça
donnerait du temps en question même la
présidente de roche mais poser la
question fait qu'elle est une stratégie
en matière de test aujourd'hui que ça je
veux être très clair
on a un double objectif
ne pas paralyser le pays et ne pas
laisser flamber l'épidémie et on a un
impératif nous répondons à la demande en
test des français si nous n'étions pas
en mesure de répondre à la demande des
tests des français on nous le
reprocherait c'était le cas il ya deux
ans donc il ya deux ans on nous disait
vous ne laissez pas assez par rapport ce
qu'il faudrait aujourd'hui commence à
monter la petite musique de vous tester
trop c'est pas parce qu'on trouve
beaucoup contestent trop
c'est parce qu'on trouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup
c'est parce qu'on retrouve beaucoup
contestent beaucoup donc nous avons une
politique de tests qui s'est voulue la
plus ambitieuse possible et qui
permettent aux français d'avoir les
résultats de leurs tests des dell dans
le délai le plus bref possible
gratuitement sauf situations
particulières la personnes non vaccinées
qui n'est pas quel contact et qui n'a
pas d'ordonnancé médicale c'est à la
marge
et nous avons voulu une politique de
tests qui se déploient partout et merci
aux pharmaciens merci aux infirmiers
merci évidemment tout ça et c'est aux
médecins qui réalise des tests nous
allons amplifier notre capacité de
réponse à la demande des français en
prenant plusieurs dispositions
complémentaires l'une de ses
dispositions ce sera permettre aux
pharmaciens qui dansait déjà vous savez
ont parfois une une tente devant la
pharmacie où peut se faire tester et
n'ont droit qu'à une seule tente nous
considérons qu'il est pharmacien
souhaite pouvoir employer par exemple
des infirmiers ou d'autres collègues
d'autres collègues soignants et non
soignants habilité à tester ils ont la
vocation s'ils le souhaitent à ne pas
avoir une seule tente d plusieurs voire
pourquoi pas développer de véritables
barnum de dépistage certains nous le
demande nous allons l'autorisé de la
même manière j'ai signé un arrêté qui
permet aux étudiants en biologie de 3e
et 4e année de tête de réaliser de là
de participer également à la campagne de
dépistage pour pouvoir faciliter la
tâche de ceux qui sont mobilisés depuis
très longtemps et d'augmenter le nombre
de bras disponibles la même manière nous
travaillons tous azimuts pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un maximum de
pharmacie sur le territoire qu'ils
puissent évidemment testé en test
antigénique mais aussi pouvoir dissous
et des boîtes auto test je le dis parce
que en difficulté remonté par un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens depuis
quelques jours et notamment je pense à
des parents d'élèves dont les qui devait
faire tester leurs enfants ou avoir des
autotests et qui disait c'est compliqué
parfois trouver des autotests de fait
nous avons un retour qui montre qu
environ deux tiers des pharmacies
met à disposition des autotests il faut
dire qu'il ya un tiers qui ne qu'il ne
le fait pas encore donc nous travaillons
avec les pharmaciens pour faire en sorte
que ce soit la totalité des pharmacies
qui demain puissent ils sont au total
sinon vous tombez sur une pharmacie qui
ne redistribue pas il ya toutes les
chances pour que la pharmacie qui soit à
côté elle en distribue il y avait
vendredi de mémoire 6 millions d'autos
teste encore en stock dans les officines
et contre 3 millions une semaine à
vendre c'est à dire que nous avons
plutôt doubler le nombre d'autos tests
disponibles dans les officines et ils
ont commandé 11 millions pour ce début
de semaine qui fait qu' on est capable
de répondre à la demande donc on
continue à chaque fois de renforcer
leurs capacités de dépistage maintenant
je vous le dit et on peut se le dire vu
le nombre de contaminations quotidienne
qu'on enregistre le nombre de cas
contacts hors norme qu'on enregistre il
n'est pas étonnant qu'on soit un nombre
de tests réalisés extrêmement important
mais si nous devions suivre le scénario
allant gleizes ou à l'africaine du sud
et que nous devions commencer à
enregistrer une diminution nous verrons
encore il faut je suis très prudent
décontamination alors la pression petit
à petit diminuera et nous redescendrons
à des niveaux de dépistage tels que ceux
que nous avons connus c'est à dire 6
millions vous ne posez pas de difficulté
n'avait pas de files d'attentes je le
redis vraiment notre à tj ne pas laisser
filer le virus ne pas paralyser le pays
et répondre à la demande
monsieur rapporteur philippe balle le
pass vaccinale vous dites est ce que ça
s'intègre dans l'urgence sanitaire on
pourrait discuter de savoir s'il faut
attendre la loi pour mettre parfois en
place des outils qui peuvent nécessiter
une mise en place urgente c'est le choix
que nous avons faits et de ne pas passer
par des arrêtés 31 31 tirs et 2 du code
de la santé publique mais de
systématiquement référé devant le
parlement à l'exception notable des
pouvoirs que vous nous avez conféré
notre demande dans la période dite de
risque sanitaire pour pouvoir à tout
moment prendre des dispositions sans en
référer au parlement je pense à la
limitation des grands rassemblements par
exemple ou au télétravail désormais
obligatoire trois ou quatre jours par
semaine pour le reste nous avons décidé
nous a référé au parlement ce qui
effectivement prend un petit peu plus de
temps mais néanmoins et je le dis je lui
ai dit en préambule monsieur le monsieur
le rapporteur
avant même que le passé vaccinale soit
adopté
les effets sont déjà visibles puisque la
simple évocation du pass vaccinale a
fait bondir le nombre de primo
vaccination dans notre pays 230 milles
pour l'essentiel plus de 200000 ce sont
des adultes je le précise parce qu'on
dit parfois c'est les enfants non pour
plus de 200 milles ce sont des adultes
et ça va continuer cette semaine ça va
continuer la semaine prochaine or nous
parlons au kw à 2 4 millions et demi de
français à peu près qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés adultes et qui sont vaccinable
si nous en faisons 200 à 300 milles par
semaine ça va vite et on arrive vite à
une couverture vaccinale plus importante
la même manière monsieur le rapporteur
il a suffi le président la république au
mois de juillet évoque le passé à lutter
pour que le soir-même souvenez-vous nous
enregistrions des bons de demandes de
rendez vous en vue d'avoir une primo
vaccination et le passé littéraire a de
ce point de vue là permis enregistré 12
7 primo vaccination de plus ce qui nous
a mis quand même dans une situation
beaucoup moins confortable que surtout
face à des vagues aussi importante que
celle ci donc le pass vaccinale est ni
l'alpha et l'oméga vous avez raison
c'est une mesure supplémentaire qui
vient s'ajouter et qui sera à notre
disposition si jamais si jamais il
devait y avoir de nouveaux variants
émergents nécessitant de garantir un
niveau de protection optimale et vous le
savez je le redis sa mort ça va de soi
c'est une évidence mais parfois les
évidences doivent être rappelés tous
ceux qui ces outils de passes sanitaire
de passes vaccinale le jour on en a plus
besoin le jour où nous sommes plus sous
la menace permanente d'un nouveau
variant nous en passeront avec beaucoup
de plaisir et même beaucoup de graisse
vous comme moi sur les listes des
organisations je vous savez que je ne
vais pas revenir je conteste
formellement le chiffre de 20% de lits
fermés à l'hôpital et toutes les études
ont montré en revanche oui l attention à
l'hôpital et la fatigue des heures sup
qui n'ont pas été prises des démissions
qui aurait dû être prise l'année
dernière mais qui n'ont pas été prises
parce que les soignants se sont dit
c'est pas le moment de partir quand ça
tape il faut qu'on reste et on partira
plus tard
vous avez des heures supplémentaires qui
ont été accumulées jusqu'à ce que les
soignants depuis ce plus d'accumuler
parce que ça faisait quand même beaucoup
trop pour eux ils sont extrêmement
courageux d'ailleurs je le dis parce que
on parle foot peut être moins de la
tension hospitalière maintenant qu'elle
est d'installer qu avant qu'elle ne
s'installe mais elle est vive 21 mille
malades dans les hôpitaux c'est beaucoup
3800 patients dans les réanimations pour
duke au vide c'est intense le nom de
déprogrammation dans notre pays a des
conséquences sur la santé des français
c'est pourquoi nous poussons vraiment à
la vaccination c'est aussi dans cet
objectif de ne pas
obérer toutes les chances pour des
patients qui ne sont pas là pour le coc
vide et qui n'ont rien demandé qu'ils
veulent juste être soignés en temps et
en heure de pouvoir être soigné et qu'on
ne soit pas obligé de garder des places
de réanimation dans l'hypothèse où des
patients non vaccinés viendrait atteint
par le cos vide
sur le risque de désorganisation c'est
pour ça encore une fois nous avons des
plans de continuité ça a été ça a été
dit j'ai parlé tout à l'heure sur la
question ce qui t'a lierre de déployer
des prises en charge pré hospitalière ou
post hospitalière c'est à dire à
domicile avec de l'oxygène sommes
capables de prendre en charge qu'à
quinze mille patients avec de l'oxygène
à domicile nous étions montés à plus de
dix mille patients lors d'une vague
précédente je crois que c'était la
deuxième ou la troisième pardonnez moi
donc nous étions bien en dessous là donc
on a réactivé ce réseau là pour pouvoir
libérer des lits hospitaliers c'est
fondamental sur la question des écoles
je ne parlerai pas au nom du ministre en
charge de l'éducation nationale même si
nous travaillons évidemment main dans la
main et que je le sais très mobilisé et
je le redis
dans des vagues précédentes avec ce
niveau de circulation du virus la
question de l'ouverture des écoles
auraient été posés monsieur le
rapporteur puisqu'elle a déjà eu
l'occasion de se poser est pris dans la
république a souhaité sanctuariser
l'école et préserver l'éducation des
petits et je me souviens qu'à chaque
fois qu'on est en cours de vagues on
parle du problème de maintenir les
écoles ouvertes à chaque fois qu'une
vague est passée on parle des
conséquences sur les enfants de des
vagues qui se sont passés des
restrictions moi je souhaite que l'on
puisse vraiment acté le fait que les
écoles ont vocation à rester ouvertes
les classes ont vocation restait ouverte
et que seul un dépistage assez intensif
nous permet de le faire mais ce
dépistage il doit être simplifié autant
que nous le pouvons en tirant constate
de ce que nous observons et encore une
fois variant nouveau contagiosité
nouvelles données nouvelles nous faisons
face en anticipant tout ce que nous
pouvons mais aussi en étant capable de
vous dire on s'adapte parce que
manifestement le dispositif qu'on a mis
en il doit être améliorée ou renforcés
pour la madame la rapporteure chantal de
seine comment résorber les inégalités
sociales et territoriales à la
vaccination je vous savez que sur tous
les territoires nous et c'est pas
nouveau gouvernement c'est nous vous les
élus locaux les associations les
médecins les pharmaciens les qui
traînait sages-femmes tout le monde
mobilise infirmiers évidemment mobilise
les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés pour
leur expliquer il ya encore sans doute
un certain nombre de français mon avis
peu nombreux qui sont vraiment très très
loin de tout qui sont vraiment des gens
qui sont parfois marginalisés donc ils
sont très très précarisés qui ont
assigné dans leur propre résidence et
qui effectivement nécessite qu'on aille
encore plus chez des marchés chez eux
mais vous avez beaucoup de gens qui sont
informés ou désinformer et parfois un
peu plus d informer qu'un former ou qui
n'ont pas confiance certains me disent
encore je discute avec quelqu'un la
semaine dernière qui misait moi c'était
un vaccin aux comprimés je le prendrais
mais c'est une injection et donc j'ai
l'impression qu'on injecte quelques
quelque chose dans mon corps mais
c'était un spray nasal ou incompris mais
oui je le prendrai même site et de la rn
message est oui c'est pas pareil ça va
pas dans la circulation massy en fait on
avale un comprimé ou contre le mal qu'on
les reçoive en spray ou qu'on les en
injection in fine et ça va au même
endroit et donc il faut pas se poser la
question donc voyez il ya parfois des
réticences face auxquels on est en butte
et pia je reviens pas là dessus sur
toutes celles et ceux qui considèrent
que nous sommes des menteurs patentés
dans une forme de délire collectif à
l'échelle planétaire et ça et d'être ici
vous avez là la solution je suis preneur
en tous les cas nous on ne s'arrête pas
là c'est pas la même vague c'est pas le
même contagiosité sur la question des
masques en extérieur et le hcsp
d'ailleurs nous avait dit en son temps
que il considérait que le port du masque
dans les milieux extérieur où le risque
était élevé s'avérait encore utile or
nous considérons que le risque est élevé
partout à l'extérieur sauf évidemment
dans les zones désertiques ou sur les
plages du fait qu' il est très très
contagieux et donc on pense qu'on peut
se contaminer plus facilement à
l'extérieur mais poser la question des
traitements qu une question fondamentale
pour vous dire qu'il ya plusieurs
médicaments qui ont vu leurs
autorisations qui étaient retirées ou
très réduite c'était très généreux et le
lilly qui sont pas des médicaments hélas
efficace sur ces nouveaux variants ça a
changé la donne et les médicaments
qu'ils étaient efficaces sur un variant
et pas forcément sur l'autre il ya ce
traitement très important j'avais lu une
tribune dans jdd il ya il ya dix jours
de cela d'associations de patients qui
écrivaient des reprises dans la
république en disant pour les patients
immunodéprimés aidez-nous avoir accès à
un traitement qui est à même de sauver
nos vies je leur réponds et d'ailleurs
je leur répond par écrit que le
traitement dont ils parlent qui est
commercialisé par astrazeneca qui
s'appelle traitement et vu chez ald qui
est précieux pour protéger les
populations à risque la france a été le
premier pays européen à proposer ce
traitement aux patients concernés et le
nombre de patients qui sont actuellement
en traitement par ce médicament grâce
aux dispositifs d'accès précoce qui a
mis en place deux prises en la
république nous sommes à plus de 2500
patients traités il y en a mille deux
cents qui sont en cours d'inclusion et
ça monte très vite donc évidemment c'est
j'ai été très sensible à cette tribune
parce que je me mets à la place de
famille ou de patients souffrant
d'immunodépression
qui entendent qu'on ne parle on parle
beaucoup de noms vacciner et de vacciner
consiste comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure
en introduction les gens immunodéprimés
qui sont à risque et 1,10 mettez nous on
n'a pas envie d'être les victimes
collatérales de tout ça il faut il faut
nous aider et donc vraiment je le redis
que l'engagement de la france et total à
leurs côtés et pour s'en convaincre je
le redis l'offre la france et à date le
seul pays européen toujours à proposer
ce traitement prophylactique aux
patients la france ne dispose plus à ce
jour d'alternative curative efficace à
face aux variants omicron mais nous
attendons d'eux déploiement d'ici la fin
de ce mois pour lesquelles nous sommes
très bien positionnés pour être parmi
les premiers fils nés les premiers à
recevoir ces médicaments c'est le pacs
le vide de pfizer traitement par voie
orale
et le saute robbie mahb médicaments gsk
qui sera administré à l'hôpital il ya
d'autres médicaments qui en reste encore
à venir qui sont en cours de
développement mais pose des questions
sur l'inspection du travail alors
isabelle borne vous répondrais bien
mieux que moi mais je me risque sous
contrôle des juristes qui m'encadrent à
vous dire que on doit pas avoir une
grille d'analysé différentes de
l'échelle des sanctions en fait
aujourd'hui on est dans un régime pénal
et on va passer dans un régime
administratif pour rendre la mesure plus
opérantes mais ça ne change pas l'esprit
nous allons prendre six
collègues ensuite leur offrant une
nouvelle vague de subir de deux
questions bernard jomier
merci madame est à présent plus mon
président et seul ministre trois courtes
question la première lorsque nous avons
auditionné dans la même configuration au
mois de début novembre vous nous aviez
déjà dit que le nombre de primo vacciner
au morte est fortement sollicitée sur 40
à 50 me ce qui n'était pas le cas mais
là cette fois ci vous avez raison
effectivement le nombre de primo
vaccinées augmente fortement et la
différence c'est que l'obligation est
arrivé dans vos propos même si c'est
sous forme déguisée ce que je regrette
les ministres n'ont pas à déguiser leur
décision mais enfin le terme est apparu
vous avez raison aussi de rappeler que
la parole du chef de l'état entraîne des
changements d'attitude chez les français
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas ce
temps perdu est ce qui n'est pas le
temps d'être franc direct et de poser le
principe de l'obligation vaccinale qui
s'ils ne convaincra jamais la petite
minorité d'anti vague fait qu'un certain
nombre de français du coup franchissent
le pas ils seront vaccinés deuxième
question vous avez rappelé que les
patients qui sont réanimation qui sont
vaccinés sont très largement des
patients immunodéprimés il ne bénéficie
pas de la prise en charge de masques
ffp2 alors qu'il mérite la protection la
meilleure contre la diffusion du vaccin
et que par exemple les patients en ald
est simple bénéficient de la prise en
charge du remboursement des masques dits
chirurgicaux
est ce que vous comptez proposer à ses
patients particulièrement fragiles qui
sont quelques centaines de milliers dans
notre pays et qui sont vaccinées des
masques ffp2 troisièmement et dernière
question un membre du conseil
scientifique a exprimé ce matin je vais
citer sa phrase directement il a dit la
stratégie de laisser circuler sans
contrôler le virus est une erreur
fondamentale c'est exactement ce qui est
fait dans les écoles au mois de novembre
alors que le nombre de classes fermées
augmenter le ministre de l'éducation a
même un temps allégé le protocole quand
appliquerez vous dans les écoles une
stratégie claire de réduction de la
circulation du virus au lieu du chaos
qui règne actuellement
alors eliane assassi en fait christine
bonfanti-dossat loïc hervé florent serra
esther benbassa
merci et madame la présidente monsieur
le président madame et messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le
ministre j'ai deux questions puisque
effectivement nous aurons l'occasion de
débattre plus longuement lors de notre
séance demain et après demain donc bien
évidemment lutter contre l'épidémie
suppose de prendre des mesures notamment
d'appeler d'inciter nos compatriotes à
la vaccination ce que nous partageons
bien évidemment et vous avez pris un
exemple dans vos propos monsieur le
ministre très démonstratif d'un monsieur
qui n'est pas anti vac celui-là qui
n'est pas anti vague mais qui
préférerait avoir autre chose qu'une
piqûre pour se faire vacciner donc il ya
encore matière à faire de la pédagogie
et à convaincre en revanche nous ne
sommes pas favorables donc à la
contrainte et je voulais déjà dit j'ai
conscience que et nous avons conscience
que le pass à lithaire a convaincu des
milliers de nos concitoyennes et donc
aux citoyens à se faire vacciner en
revanche force est de constater que cela
n'a pas empêché la prog la propagation
du virus même si aujourd'hui le variant
au micro et moins dangereux que aimé et
moins dangereux oui que le vario delta
même si au beacon est très très très
contagieux donc ce tout ça nous
interroge sur votre choix de passer du
pass a dit r opaque vaccinale dont
l'application va entre autres entraves
et les libertés et en la matière la
sémantique et quelquefois très magique
deuxième quai ses premières questions
donc le seul ministre avez vous un bilan
précis de l'usaj dupas sanitaires et
deuxième question mais vous avez
l'habitude parce que j'ai l'occasion de
la pose et à chaque fois que j'en ai
l'occasion
mais qui restent sans réponse cela
repose aujourd'hui car nous sommes
content qu'on confronté à une pandémie
et donc à une question mondiale or seuls
50 % de la population mondiale
et vaccinés ne serait-il pas temps
monsieur le ministre que les 50 % de la
population mondiale qui n'est pas
vacciné est dans état puisse avoir accès
aux preuves au brevet pour avoir le
droit de se faire vacciner merci
christine bonfanti-dossat merci madame
la présidente le seul ministre l'année
2022 s'annonce aussi compliquée que 2021
21 parce que nous ne verrons
probablement pas le bout de la crise
sanitaire sauf à en croire
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
s'interroge sérieusement sur la
stratégie qui consiste à accélérer la
vaccination dans les pays riches ce que
vous êtes en train de faire monsieur le
ministre alors qu'il faudrait prioriser
les pays pauvres où une très grande
majorité de la population n'a pas reçu
la première dose il faudrait toujours
d'après l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
si l'on veut reprendre le contrôle de
cette pandémie que 70% de la population
de chaque pays soient vaccinés dans les
six mois
alors que le président de la république
règle ses comptes à ok qu'ovide avec les
non vaccinés alors que le premier
ministre parle déjà de quatrième dose de
plus en plus de personnes dont je suis
monsieur le ministre s'interroge et
doutes sur l'efficacité sanitaire du
pass d'accident monsieur le ministre ne
pensez vous pas que le plus urgent
aujourd'hui au lieu de vouloir accélérer
la vaccination comme vous le faite de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour vacciner le
monde entier
loïc hervé ensuite
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre j'aurais aimé vous interroger
sur le protocole appliqua dans les
écoles et la désorganisation massive que
nous connaissons ces jours ci dans
l'éducation nationale j'aurais aussi
aimé vous interroger sur les
conséquences économiques des
modifications des règles du pass
sanitaire en france sur le tourisme à
l'égard la clientèle étrangère dans la
perspective des vacances de février mais
j'y reviendrai en séance monsieur le
ministre au micro déferle sur la france
et chaque jour des centaines de millions
de français
vacciner ou non sont contaminés vacciner
triple dose j'en ai fait moi même
l'expérience la semaine dernière les
chers collègues nous en sommes tous
témoins dans notre entourage tous
témoins de ce qui se passe dans notre
pays à elle seule cette réalité aurait
dû nous démontrer l'inutilité sanitaires
d'une grande partie des mesures
privatives de liberté au premier rang
desquels le pas salutaire mais tel un
mantra vous continuer de répéter que
l'objectif du passe aujourd'hui
sanitaire demain vaccinale et créent des
lieux sans contagiosité devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale vous avez déclaré je vous cite
on va continuer de resserrer les mailles
pour pouvoir garantir non seulement que
les endroits recevant du public sont
indemnes de gens potentiellement
contagieux à mes yeux le moment est
évidemment venu de lever la plupart des
restrictions aux libertés publiques et
nous les renforcer c'est pourquoi j'ai
déposé un amendement à l'article 1er qui
propose non seulement de renoncer au
pass vaccinale mais de supprimer
purement et simplement le passé l'état
dans notre pays monsieur le ministre
pouvait vous devant la commission des
lois composé de gens sérieux et
rationnel revenir sur cette affirmation
selon laquelle le pass protégerait de la
contamination et à défaut de le faire
devant la cnil qui vous les a demandé à
moult reprises pour vous transmettre au
parlement des éléments objectifs et
chiffré qui étaient vos affirmations je
vous remercie
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je suis d'abord là pour relayer
l'inquiétude est là l'épuisement des
soignants libéraux cette fois-ci ya pas
que les hôpitaux des infirmiers font des
autotests actuellement et on me montre
quand même particulièrement que le prix
du matériel à quadruples est quasiment 2
en particulier les gants est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de donner une aide sur
ce secteur là je vais pas revenir sur
les tests et la désorganisation en
particulier quand la contradiction entre
auto test test pcr et antigénique skis
et ski et leur pain quotidien
je voudrais vous poser des questions
précises sur le sur l'anticipation par
l'utilisation des de la détection dans
les vous m'écoutez mme sioniste oui oui
l'anticipation dans la détection dans
les stations d'épuration et les égouts
qui permet qui a permis avec le réseau b
pin de détecter à peu près 15 jours à
l'avance les vagues successives et de
les affiner selon les endroits où est-ce
qu'on en est de ces de ses
préconisations et est ce que vous
comptez sur cette utilisation
deuxièmement on a également beaucoup
parlé des capteurs de co2 des
purificateurs d'air
qui apporterait en particulier des
endroits qu'on a du mal à ventiler
apporterait vraiment un plus il ya des
pays qui se sont massivement mis à les
utiliser puisque finalement l'endroit où
on se contaminent à l'heure actuelle
c'est l'école al aoula où il n'y a pas
de vaccin ou peu de vaccins je m'arrête
là ce qui est encore certainement
beaucoup de questions
esther benbassa
merci de me donner la parole d'abord je
dirais que je suis triple vacciner et
j'étais aussi malade du coc vite donc je
ne suis pas anti vax
voilà
d'abord je voudrais vous demander s'il y
a vraiment une nécessité de une chance
pour passer du poste sanitaire au passé
vaccinale et nous n'avons aucune donnée
sur l'efficacité du cac sanitaires ni
des données sur le pass
vaccinale le conseil constitutionnel
doit vérifier la nécessité et la
proportionnalité de ce texte ensuite je
me pose la question sur la suivante
alisation de la parole médical qui
classe cette panique et qui permet
également un directement et
indirectement est un bon superflu 2
de restreindre nos libertés
alors c'est un sou mentalisation est
assez étonnante parce que
la question des hôpitaux plan le manque
de personnel ce ne sont pas des
questions nouvelles ce discours
médicalisé ne fait que cacher la réalité
depuis enfin avant même l'arrivée de
monsieur macro et de son gouvernement au
pouvoir et les hôpitaux poser des vraies
questions de ge et de mauvaise gestion
de la santé alors
il faut prendre d'autres mesures aussi
arrêter les tests pour les gens sans
symptôme se sert à rien essayez de deux
de ne pas créer cette stigmatisation
d'une partie de la population qui ne
veut pas se vacciner ceux qui auraient
été réglés par un vaccin obligatoire par
une vaccination obligatoire et nous
sommes là dans une sorte de crise
on ne guérit pas c'est vrai qu'il ya une
personne sur quatre qui est contaminée
parmi les triples vacciner donc il
faudrait peut-être
essayer de 2 de prendre d'autres mesures
et renforçaient les barrières
essayer de convaincre davantage surtout
en zone rurale fr avoir des référents
qui vont dans les chais les gens pour
les combats n'y est arrêté ces mesures
qui se multiplient pour ne pas vexer
faire un vaccin une vaccination
obligatoire
merci
commencer le ministre voulait répondre
cette première série de questions
volontiers où j'ai parlé d' obligation
vaccinale déguisé dans une dans une
interview ça m'a été rappelé en quelques
occasions
serge aubin je sais pas si c'est une
obligation vaccinale déguisé en tout cas
c'est une
formule qui me paraît
je peux me tromper plus efficace qu'une
obligation vaccinale skate au sens où
sauf à me démontrer que vous êtes
capable d'identifier parce que ce qu'il
dit obligation dit contrôler 10 qui dit
contrôler 10 sanctions si vous
identifier un niveau de sanction
qui est susceptible de faire basculer
quelqu'un qui considère que le facteur
avec le vaccin vous voulez lui inoculer
je ne sais quel poison
et le oui monsieur le sénateur il ya
mains des anti pacs bernard c'est pas
une minorité de gens parmi ce que
cherche vacciner dans cette année il ya
des gens qui disent que c'est
obligatoire il le ferait mais vous savez
il ya beaucoup de gens aussi qui
considérait que s'ils ne pouvais plus
aller au bar restaurant se fassent
vacciner ils seraient vaccinés
d'ailleurs ça tombe bien puisqu'il le
fond de cette riche en train d'un
dialogue au sein des commissions mais
avec avec plaisir l'extérieur si vous le
souhaitez
si vous voulez le le il ya une
recommandation très claire pour le port
de masques ffp2 pour les personnes qui
souffrent d'immunodépression de
pathologies d'ailleurs qui donne lieu à
un remboursement dans un certain nombre
de situations je les rêves évidemment à
ce que personne ne soit privé de masques
ffp2 pour des questions de coûts dès
lors qu'ils se verraient prescrire ces
masques ce qui est le cas d'un grand
nombre de personnes immunodéprimées dans
notre pays d'ailleurs avec ou sans que
coronavirus il faut le savoir j'ai eu
plusieurs questions sur la question sur
le sujet des écoles je le redis un
notre notre objectif c'est de réduire la
circulation du virus dans les écoles est
de maintenir les écoles ouvertes il faut
donc avec ces deux principes que nous
trouvions le dispositif qui soit le plus
à même de nous permettre de garder un
oeil actifs sur l'évolution de
l'épidémie chez les enfants et en même
temps de ne pas rendre les choses
inopérante ou trop compliqué pour les
parents j'ai entendu notamment nous
avons entendu qu'un certain nombre de
parents se sont trouvés en difficulté
lorsqu'ils apprenaient la veille au soir
qu'un enfant dans leur culte dans la
classe de leur enfant d'être contaminés
pour se trouver un test à j0 qui sont un
test anti génie coupé cr c'est peut-être
compliqué quand vous êtes dans une
période de vastes circulation de virus
et que accéder à la pharmacie peut-être
compliqué peut se poser peu se pose est
peut-être la question je ne fais pas ici
d'annoncés de réponse un travail
interministériel qui doivent conduire
mais de savoir si on peut faciliter
peut-être l'accès aux auto test dès le
premier test qui serait peut-être de
nature à je dirais simplifier la vie
d'un certain de parents nous allons voir
encore une fois cela je le dis en toute
en toute simplicité à chaque fois que
nous voyons qu'un protocole doit être
réajusté
le rendre encore plus opérationnel et
vivable pour les français nous le
faisons et nous le ferons dans la durée
j'ai répondu sur cette question sur les
doses les dons de doses aux pays pauvres
d'abord la france est le premier est
l'un des premiers contributeurs au monde
et c'est à la demande du président de la
république c'est factuel c'est dans les
tablettes pouvez regarder que a été
monté un dispositif très tôt de dons de
pays des pays les plus aisés vers les
pays les plus en difficultés pour
accéder aux contrats tout le monde n'a
pas la chance de faire partie de l'union
européenne et d'avoir un accès à des
commandes massif auprès des laboratoires
au moins chaque français a donné au
moins déjà une dose à un pays pauvre et
ce sera bientôt deux doses par français
donnés à des pays pauvres ça n'est pas
incompatible de vacciner les français de
vacciner le monde et c'est une nécessité
que de continuer de renforcer la
politique vaccinale notamment à
destination des pays les plus pauvres
parce que c'est une protection pour eux
mais c'est aussi protection pour nous
puisque plus vite la planète sera
vacciné plus nous aurons de chances de
ne pas voir apparaître de nouveaux
variants dangereux donc je n'oppose pas
les deux
une question qui était posée par le
sénateur loïc hervé qui vous êtes dans
une continuité vis-à-vis du pass
sanitaires et dubé donc évidemment du
pass vaccinale si vous êtes dans
l'opposition au ce que j'entends bien
d'abord vous rappeler que le conseil
d'état l'a validé que le conseil
scientifique l'appelle de ses voeux et
le conte et le pass solitaire et
maintenant le pass vaccinale que
certains pays ont fait le choix d'aller
plus loin c'est notamment le pass 2 g
plus en allemagne c'est un pass
vaccinale plus sanitaire cd il faut être
totalement vacciner et présenter un test
moi j'ai envie de vous prendre le
raisonnement inverse monsieur le
sénateur vous dites moi j'ai un
amendement qui supprime le pass et qui
supprime ces mesures dans l'est dans les
endroits dans lesquels le pass
s'applique ça veut dire que vous êtes en
train d'expliquer avec votre amendement
s'il était adopté que demain alors
qu'une somme de 300 mille contamination
par jour on pourrait aller au restaurant
ou dans les bars on pourrait se
rassembler en milieu clos manger chanter
rire danser en étant ni vacciné ni
tester
m'aiderez supprimer le pass solitaire en
l'état avec un amendement qui supprime
ces mesures là ça ça veut dire ça tient
de demain on dit aux français en fait
alesi et puis advienne que pourra le yen
que pourra il ya très peu de pays qui
ont essayé au monde généralement ils ont
changé de cap assez vite quand il s'est
rendu compte que les vagues étaient trop
hautes et l'impact sanitaire trop
importants dans leur pays la question
sur les eaux usées en fait on continue
de travailler avec beaucoup de stations
et le réseau aubépines la sénatrice il y
a des moments il ya des stations où on a
des données qui étaient plus ou moins
conformes à l'attendu des endroits où
c'était encore je dirais à conforter
d'un point de vue scientifique et
notamment on l'avait vu l'hiver dernier
que la montée des eaux que l'hydre
attaque le les pluies que la fonte des
neiges emporté des conséquences
puisqu'il avait entraîné des dilutions
plus importante des traces de virus dans
les eaux usées et donc il y avait pas
une règle très clair qui permettait
d'avoir de définir quels étaient niveau
précis de circulation d'épidémie sage
chercher cela étant je mangeais dans
toutes lés toutes les semaines dans mes
dossiers j'ai cette question d'aider des
traces de virus dans les eaux usées
qu'on regarde avec intérêt notamment
plutôt dans les périodes où ça circule
beaucoup moins pour voir s'il ya des
signes précoces de ré émergence là la
situation actuelle fait que vous
cherchez des traces du virus dans les
eaux usées vous allez retrouver
puisqu'il y en a absolument partout pour
madame la sénatrice benbassa un peu dans
la même logique quand vous dites vous
dites on instrumentalise la parole
médicale egis après fait une affirmation
que je ne me permettrais pas de faire ni
comme médecin du comme ministre je dis
ça sans mais vous n'êtes dire je vous
cite on devrait arrêter ce tester les
gens sans symptôme parce que ça ne sert
à rien mais moi je ne sais pas madame la
sénatrice ça sert à rien je crois plutôt
que ça ne sert pas à rien j'ai même
quasiment convaincu du contraire 1 vous
pouvez ne pas avoir de symptômes est
parfaitement contagieuse
et donc si vous ne restez pas les gens
qui sont qu'à contacter par exemple qui
sont à risque d'être contaminé de ne pas
le savoir parce qu'ils sont vaccinés
mais qui peuvent quand même transmettre
le virus vous risquez d'avoir une
diffusion du virus encore plus
importante
donc on peut pas dire des choses comme
celles ci vous voyez pas ce que on donne
après le sentiment aux français qu'en
fait tu aurais d'aider des questions qui
ce qui donnerait lieu à interprétation
factuellement je n'ai plus honte est
plus on trouve plus on trouve plus on
préserve ceux qui ne sont pas conçus qui
ne sont pas encore touchés et plus on
amoindri l'ampleur d'une vague
épidémique donc réjouissons-nous lettre
api qui teste beaucoup et
réjouissons-nous d'être peut-être
bientôt un pays qui testera un peu moins
vrai qu'il y aura moins de cas positifs
parce que la vague sera passé
et enfin tu devais faire une analogie
j'aime pas trop mais ben même pas ça je
dirais pas ce que vous dites le vaccin
finalement ils ont peut être on peut
être algérie 3 d'eau j'ai eu le virus
etc voyez dans ce cas là le si vous le
souhaitez le vaccin comme un double
airbag
2 airbags dans votre voiture il vous en
empêchera pas d'avoir un accident de
voiture si vous devez rentrer en
collision avec un autre véhicule donc
j'ai un double airbag mais j'ai eu un
accident ouais mais j'ai un double
airbags dont j'ai eu la vie sauve
non mais je ne dis pas un exploit que
vous avez dit le contraire je vous
propose dans le prolongement de la
discussion cette analogie j'ai un double
airbag j'ai eu la vie sauve j'avais pas
double airbag la baisse de mortalité
routière l'une des principales mesures
qui a fait baisser la mortalité routière
notre pays c'est la sécurisation des
véhicules et donc on apporte de plus en
plus de sécurité et ça permet deux mais
c'est pas parce que vous avez un double
airbag que vous allez rouler à 170 sinon
le risque d'avoir un accident il sera
encore très important voyez j'arrête là
l'analogie mais c'était vraiment pourra
essayer de visualiser les choses
merci monsieur munitions de continuer
d'essayer des questions quand beaucoup
de monde à madame valérie boyer puis
madame laurence cohen ensuite monsieur
alain richard monsieur olivier henno
monsieur jean yves le conte et madame
laurence rossignol madame boyer merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre avant de commencer mon propos
je
permettez moi de vous faire part de mon
émotion face aux propos du président de
la république je crois ici que nous
sommes dans une assemblée sérieuse et
que de façon quasi unanime nous sommes
pour le vaccin l'obligation est un autre
débat et nous l'avons eue ici d'ailleurs
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
passer à autre chose bien sûr vous aurez
toujours des français qui sont opposés à
la vaccination et ce débat est loin
d'être nouveau à titre personnel je le
regrette mais je le répète depuis le
début je ne crois pas la contrainte et
encore moins à la vulgarité et surtout a
demandé à la représentation nationale de
faire des choses qui ne sont pas pour le
bien des français mais pour les embêter
pour ne pas employer ces termes
il est de votre responsabilité
d'expliquer aux français en quoi votre
stratégie serait la bonne et surtout de
faire preuve de cohérence nous le savons
désormais le bac ça n'empêche pas le
virus de circuler il a des effets
positifs bien sûr mais des français
veulent savoir en quoi le pass vaccinale
peut limiter la propagation du virus
pourquoi vacciner des personnes qui ont
un taux d'anticorps élevé est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre à cette question
concernant le pass
peut-être allez-vous répondre qu'il
permet d'éviter la cites la saturation
encore des services de réanimation
dans ce cas pourquoi avoir poursuivi la
fermeture de lits de réanimation le
nombre de 5700 suppressions de lits a
été évoquée je voudrais savoir ce qu'il
en est de façon précise
pourquoi dans ce cas ne pas avoir ouvert
des ré a particulièrement mobile ou
temporaire comme cela a été suggéré est
ce le manque de personnel et pourquoi
avoir mis à pied du personnel non
vaccinés
pourquoi ne pas faire peser enfin faire
peser des risques aux malades et dans ce
cas pourquoi autoriser désormais le
personnel positive au co vide à
travailler mais pas le personnel non
vaccinés à moins que ce soient des
fausses informations et dans ce cas
j'aimerais bien avoir la réponse alors
nous le savons tous il y à une élection
présidentielle dans moins de 90 jours
qui pourrait nous enfermer dans des
postures mais je crois que rien ne
justifie l'insulté et l'invectivé et
c'est une pas ça qui va rassurer les
gens pour qu'ils puissent être vacciné
je dirais bien au contraire ça risque de
les braquer et rien ne justifie non plus
les menaces répétées du gouvernement en
cherchant à stigmatiser une partie des
français considéraient comme des
sous-citoyens aussi une manière
solennelle monsieur le ministre je
voudrais que vous puissiez rassurer les
français apaiser notre nation et
maintenir la cohésion nationale et enfin
j'aurai une dernière remarque à faire je
voudrais saluer ici concernant les eaux
usées comme l'a souligné notre collègue
le magnifique travail réalisé par les
marins pompiers de marseille qui permet
effectivement même si c'est pas un outil
parfait mais de suivre pour cette
épidémie comme pour d'autres à l'avenir
l'évolution de
des maladies en tout cas c'est un
travail d'une grande qualité que nous ne
pouvons que saluer je vous remercie
merci laurence cohen ou non pas chacun
d'état ces concepts que nous avons
encore une quinzaine de questions merci
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
ministre pour votre propos vos propos
introductif vous avez noté à juste titre
l'engagement des personnels soignants et
des personnels d'une manière générale
à la fois du secteur de la santé mais du
secteur aussi médicaux médico social
mais en même temps il son bord de
l'épuisement vous l'avez dit aussi et
les conditions de travail ne cesse de se
dégrader alors vous allez me répondre
mais il ya eu le ségur mais on voit on
sait aux rencontres puisqu'il ya des
auditions en ce moment il ya une
commission d' enquête sur la situation
des hôpitaux et les personnels toutes
catégories confondues nous disent que ça
n'est plus possible que les conditions
sont extrêmement difficiles et qu'il
faut ré embaucher du personnel et pour
ça il faut modifier les conditions de
travail donc ma question est simple
quelle mesure vous allez prendre pour
justement faire face à ce manque de
personnel comment vous allez rendre plus
attractif ces professions ça veut dire
donc en améliorant les conditions de
travail et c'est pas seulement des
augmentations salariales ça va plus loin
et quel plan de formation massif vous
avez l'intention de mettre en place ce
qu'il faut le faire dès aujourd'hui si
on veut arrêter donc cette hémorragie
parce que ils partent comme vous l'avez
d'ailleurs dit sur la pointe des pieds
ou avec fracas tellement la situation
est difficile et ma deuxième question
plus courte c'est sur l'article 1 vous
avez décidé de prolonger les dispositifs
d'accompagnement des médecins du secteur
privé victime de déprogrammation
répétées de soins non urgents je crois
jusqu'au 30 juin de 2022 ma question est
simple c'est pourquoi vous n'est pas
étendu cette mesure au secteur public
et j'aimerais effectivement que vous
puissiez nous apporter une réponse parce
que contenu de l'article 40 ça ne pourra
pas faire de notre part obligatoirement
l'objet d'un des moments où ça sera
assez difficile vous remercie
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez mentionné
une propension la transmission du virus
qui serait diminuée je crois pas être
terme était de moitié
dans le cas de vaccination
et je devrais savoir
comment s'expriment les différentes
composantes de la communauté
scientifique sur ce sujet car il m'a
semblé qu'il était encore assez discuté
et qui avaient des hypothèses assez
opposées qui qui s'opposent ceux qui se
présentaient la seconde question c'est
que vous avez mentionné le très gros
effort qui est fait dans le réseau
pharmaceutiques pour la diffusion des
tests et notamment des autotests
vous avez jugé nécessaire et je partage
cette appréciation de faire diffuser
également les autotests par le réseau de
la grande distribution
seulement pour un mois pour des raisons
d'équilibré économique que l'on comprend
bien mais est-ce que à l'heure actuelle
vous voyez
une réponse effective de la grande
distribution à ceux à cette mission
parce qu'il semble pliée au contraire
beaucoup de phénomènes de saturation et
de déficit de livres et de livraison
dans la grande distribution
enfin puisque vous évoquiez le système
kovacs
est-ce qu'il est partagé par d'autres
puissants se
développer et est ce qu on est en route
vers un niveau de l'accident à sion dans
l'année qui vient significative des pays
en développement
les vienneau oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre j'ai
voté le pass annie terre je veux très
probablement le passo vaccinale est
pourtant voyez vous j'ai un doute plus
important sur la pertinence de la mesure
et sur son efficacité pourquoi parce que
au fond ça change pour qui ce passe
vaccinale pour les personnes qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et préféré se faire tester
à leurs frais et qui bénéficié de ce
pass
sanitaires ils sont à mon sens assez peu
nombreux sans doute à avoir utilisé ces
tests payant est ce que d'ailleurs d'un
certain point de vue en un certain
nombre de statistiques sur ces questions
donc texte utile ou textes de
communication voilà la question que je
me posais et celle ci est maintenant sur
les vaccins une question un peu voisine
de de celle du sénateur richard
de monsieur le ministre
quand même les anti vaccins sont le
procès de la dangerosité du vaccin on
pourrait aussi quand même faire le
procès de leur relative inefficacité moi
dans ma famille tout le monde a fait
trois doses respecter les gestes
barrière être prudents on brasse plus on
sert plus la main tout le monde a eu
copie de ces temps derniers sans
exception pratiquement et mon fils
genre c'est bien jamais mais quand même
je n'en mets ma question n'est pas celle
là mc ma question est la suivante est ce
que vous voyez avec la commande la
communauté scientifique un horizon pour
des vaccins il s'agit pas de les
remettre en cause mais des ave des
vaccins plus efficaces qui permettrait
d'en finir avec cette maladie et de
renforcer encore limoux noter que
l'immunité collective est ce qu'il ya
une ou un horizon sur eux sur cette
question de l'amélioration encore de
l'efficacité des vaccins je vous
remercie
monsieur le comte jeudi à chacun d'entre
nous surtout me pose la question
une prise de parole une question merci à
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
trois courtes question la première qu'en
est il des personnes qui ont des contre
indications médicales aux vaccins
seront elles privées par construction du
pass du pass vaccinale ou d'un
équivalent monsieur le fur a posé la
question à l'assemblée nationale me
semble-t-il sans réponse précise
deuxième question monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous prendre l'engagement
si je pouvais vous prendre l'engagement
que les personnes qui ont eu des débuts
ou des parcours vaccinale à l'étranger
pourront
obtenir un pass vaccinale alors qu'on
sait que au delà de la reconnaissance
des vaccins maintenant il ya des
philosophies différentes d'un pays à
l'autre en matière de troisième dose est
ce que vous pouvez prendre l'engagement
qu'il y aura un arrêté ou un décret qui
dira comment quel que soit le début de
parcours vaccinale on pourra avoir accès
à un pass vaccinale en france enfin
troisième question dans l'article 2 du
projet de loi on prévoit de donner les
informations relatives qui sont contenus
dans dans 6 des ppte en matière de
résultats des tests aux services
préfectoraux pouvez vous nous dire
exactement ce qu'il en est et à quel
usage est ce qu'il s'agit de transmettre
l'ensemble des informations ou
simplement d information qui permettrait
de libérer de quarantaine des personnes
qui ont eu des tests négatifs je vous
remercie merci
dans une question la première est assez
simple dans la loi du 5 août on avait
prévu par l'amendement mais la deuxième
ne seront aussi ouverts et monsieur le
ministre là on avait prévu par
amendement que pour la vaccination des
enfants l'autorisation parentale d'un
seul des deux parents su s'il suffisait
j'ai une petite j'ai un petit doute sur
le texte tel qu'il sorte de l'assemblée
nationale est ce que cette
facilité est reprise est-ce qu'elle
s'applique deux ans de par conséquence
ou est-ce qu'il va s que nous avons la
mission de d'amender le texte de
l'assemblée pour reprendre la règle de
la loi du 5 août
bon une fois que vous aurez à prendre ma
deuxième question c'est que vous savez
vous mener plusieurs débats au parlement
avec les différentes sensibilités du
parlement vous savez que celui que vous
menez avec nous les socialistes n'est
pas un débat sur le but sur le vaccin
c'est un débat sur l'obligation
vaccinale l'efficacité en termes de
santé publique de l'obligation vaccinale
comparée à celle d'abord du passé ni
terre et maintenant du pass vaccinale ma
question est simple plus comme ennemi
mais madame et monsieur le président
nous nous presse est ce que votre
conscience demain après demain pour
qu'on puisse avoir ce débat avec vous
[Applaudissements]
allez on continue d'essayer des
questions courtes on va aller vite
mangas tels malheurs même gatel merci
monsieur le président madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre j'ai
trois petites questions très courte
l'ouverture de l'école c'est une très
bonne chose mais on sait qu'on gagne la
guerre grâce à l'intendance or
aujourd'hui c'est fort compliquée pour
les familles de pouvoir tester leurs
enfants jusqu'à trois fois par semaine
et les petits enfants ont beaucoup de
mal avec certains tests pourquoi
aujourd'hui nous devrons pas davantage
au test salivaire il semblerait qu'au
micro puisque le permettre deuxièmement
j'ai une question sur les faux-pas
sanitaire est ce qu on sait le nombre de
faux pas de sanitaires qu'il y a est-ce
que vous pensez que le dispositif que
vous proposez de repentance en quelque
sorte encouragera les gens à se faire
vacciner et troisième question pour
l'avenir
quid des personnes qui sont victimes de
kovy blond et qui voit à la fois leur
vie professionnelle mais aussi leur vie
personnelle et sociale totalement
bouleversé est ce que vous avez eu le
temps pensez peut-être pas encore mais
certainement un jour vous poserez vous
la question monsieur mini de pouvoir
leur octroyer le bénéfice des
dispositions ld merci monsieur le
ministre victor jasmin
la présidente monsieur le président
monsieur ministres au mois de juillet
dernier j'évoquais déjà les difficultés
concernant l'efficacité des vaccins que
vous proposiez j'avais même dit qu'il y
avait une vraie difficulté avec la
cinétique d'instinet et la réponse
immunitaire et on passait à ce moment-là
à une éventuelle troisième dose
maintenant parler de 4e love d'après ce
que me disait monsieur delfraissy a pas
bien longtemps donc on s'interroge
vraiment si l'efficacité ça a déjà été
dit par certains de mes collègues
d'autre part le vaccin que vous proposez
n'empêche pas les empêche pas la
contamination n'empêche pas d'être
malade enfin bon c'est en fait une
prévision une prévention de la durée et
la difficulté qui se pose aujourd'hui
dans certains de nos hôpitaux c'est que
des professionnels qui pourraient
peut-être travailler tout simple mais
qui pourrait justifier avec un pass
vaccinale de la négativité de leur
théologie et bien aujourd'hui sont
suspendus alors que ce que vous proposez
est ce que ce ne serait pas pertinent là
où en tout cas ce sera nécessaire parce
qu il y a également la couverture par
rapport aux soins dupont qui sont en
danger pour les patients qui sont en
danger parce qu'il faut savoir également
que il ya deux ans au moment du plfss
nous avions cessé nos travaux justement
parce que dans beaucoup d'hôpitaux
beaucoup de soignants et ses regrets
pour les moyens particulièrement les
moyens humains aujourd'hui en suspendant
ces professionnels ils sont diplômés qui
savent de quoi il s'agit donc ce sont
des personnes qui connaissent vraiment
ce que c'est et pourquoi ils ont fait le
choix ne pas se faire vacciner pour le
moment eh bien on se passe de ces
personnes là à quel prix à quel prix
alors aujourd'hui j'en prends que je
vous demande vraiment est-ce que entre
ces personnes qui ne sont probablement
pas vaccinés qui devrait peut-être le
faire là c'est un devoir mais et les
personnes qui sont vaccinées qui sont
malades quelle serait la différence par
rapport aux soins qu'il pourrait
apporter dans certains de nos
établissements
merci on va prendre toutes les questions
parce qu'il ya souvent des réponses
communes à des questions qui parfois
sont très proches les unes des autres
catherine du folk oh
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre je vais revenir sur le sujet
déjà abordé par madame cohen
concernant les hôpitaux et puis le
compléter peut-être donc cette pandémie
a révélé en réalité le malaise qui
existe dans nos services hospitaliers
nous pouvons effectivement salué le
travail considérable qui est réalisé par
par les personnels les remercier pour
leur engagement à tous les niveaux je
suis là si vous me cherchez c'est ça
voilà
voilà donc je disais remercié
effectivement tout le tout le personnel
pour le niveau d'engagement sur tous les
postes et puis comprendre leur état de
fatigue au terme de ces deux années très
difficiles tous les jours nous entendons
des informations qui sont alarmantes sur
les activités des services d'urgence et
de réanimation parle beaucoup de
déprogrammation d'opération je voudrais
savoir ce qu'il en est de la prise en
charge par les établissements
hospitaliers privés dans cette pandémie
dans la prise en charge des patients
atteints de colite sont ils réellement
sollicité pour venir en aide aux
hôpitaux publics merci monsieur guy
laroche qui est en visio
la première en une minute le vous avez
dit que le premier texte il était
question de loi d'urgence pour aux
seules familles étaient contre la
propagation de l'épidémie vous parlez
plus de lutter contre la propagation
dans cette fois vous avez supprimé
termes de propagation est-ce que vous
assumez donc votre politique que vous
pourriez tout à fait assumée qui est
d'abandonner la lutte contre la
propagation et d'avoir laissé ce virus
pour les réseaux qui n'en a pas discuté
se répandre deuxième question vous
parlait d'aller vers la population
marginale et vous dites que c'est que
des lots vaccinaux essentiellement
réfractaires l'étude de l'isq de
l'inserm qui a été menée sur un petit
échantillon montre qu'il ya 40% le
répétons que ce soit un peu moins de
gens qui en fait principalement des
difficultés et d'accès à la vaccination
comme les immigrés les personnes âgées
ou tu ce qu'ils soient isolés
socialement la troisième je vous avais
interrogé avant la troisième dose en
vous demandant quelles étaient vos
intentions en séance du sénat il n'avait
pas eu de réponse alors que juste après
vous avez intégré la troisième dose dans
le passo sanitaire ma question et
qu'elle soit vous êtes sur la quatrième
dose savez vous quel type de quatrième
dose vous allez mettre à disposition
corp et pour qui je terminerai en disant
que les masques ffp2 à montrer leurs
oeufs avantage sur les autres masques
envisagez vous de les distribuer de
mettre à disposition gratuitement
par exemple les professeurs des écoles
jean seule
madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
vous évoquiez il ya quelques instants la
possibilité d'une prise en charge à
domicile pour les patients ont notamment
dans l'état de santé nécessite de
l'oxygène est ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer que nous avons assez de stock
en matière d'oxygène aujourd'hui en
france suffisant parce que ça ne fait
pas partie des des retours que nous
avons ma deuxième question pourquoi les
délais de réinjection varité leur
régulièrement un au départ vous nous
parliez de cinq mois 4 mois 3 mois le
directeur de la ms lui-même vient de
mettre en garde sur cette stratégie
incompréhensible en précisant la
répétition des doses n'est pas une
solution
qu'envisagez vous alors envisagez-vous
une quatrième une cinquième voire une
sixième dose et dans quel délai enfin
combien de lits de réanimation sont
effectivement disponibles aujourd'hui et
les ressources donc soignante
pourront-elles être mise donc seront
elles opérationnel pour s'occuper des
patients qui occuperont éventuellement
celi merci merci monsieur patrick kanner
merci monsieur le président la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous
avez tout à l'heure utiliser l'adage
advienne que pourra en général on le
précède de l'expression fais ce que dois
advienne que pourra c'était
l'expression prince favorite de gaston
monnerville dans cette belle assemblée
fais ce que dois
depuis six mois deux comités de liaison
parlementaire en comité de lison
parlementaire vous me reconnaîtrez le
fait que je demande l'obligation
vaccinale au nom du groupe que j'ai
l'honneur de présider
la réponse systématique de jean castex
ou la vôtre était mais non c'est
impossible à mettre en oeuvre et puis
nous sommes arrivés sur la notion
d'obligation déguisés pour reprendre
votre expression même si aujourd'hui
vous l'avez un petit peu je dirais
timoré regard de vos explications ma
question et sa ministre
le 30 juillet 2021 il y a eu il y avait
112 mille morts de lakovic 19 dans notre
pays sans doute minimum
six mois plus tard nous sommes à 126
mille morts la question s'est elle est
très simple si l'obligation vaccinale
avaient été mises en oeuvre est-ce que
vous pensez que nous aurions pu éviter
une partie de ces morts
alors mélanie vos jacquet en visio et à
qui je souhaite la bienvenue puisque
vous allez nouvelle la commission des
affaires sociales
merci bonjour merci de la bienvenue
monsieur ministre très rapidement tout
d'abord pour vous reposer la question
vous avez dit vous avez répondu à une
question qui vous avaient été posées sur
les dons de doses je crois que cette
question ne vous a pas été posée la
question qui vous avait été posée c'est
sur la levée des brevets
pas eu de réponse à une question qui est
très importante pour nous je vous
remercie de nous dire si la france
compte changer de position et appuyer
cette demande de certains pays pour
pouvoir produire eux mêmes les vaccins
et certains laboratoires des centaines
disent que c'est possible
la deuxième question c'est sur le profil
des personnes non vaccinées vous nous
aviez dit récemment qu ils sont divisés
grosso modo en trois catégories les
personnes isolées les personnes
indifférentes et les personnes
récalcitrantes réfractaires est ce que
vous auriez des chiffres un peu plus
précis à nous donner sur la composition
de la population non vaccinée et enfin
pour compléter la question de mon
collègue jean yves le conte sur les
français et françaises qui sont à
l'étranger en dehors du problème qui
existe des personnes qui ont eu un
schéma vaccinal complet à l'étranger
il y a un problème avec des personnes
qui ont eu un schéma vaccinal complet en
france mais qui résident à l'étranger et
qu'ils sont infectés à l'étranger et la
france ne reconnaît pas leur certificat
de rétablissement leurs tests pcr
positif et ces gens se retrouvent dans
une situation totalement aberrante
puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas faire de
troisième dose puisqu'ils viennent
d'être affectés que donc c'est interdit
ils ne peuvent pas y avoir accès il ne
vaut mieux pas d'un point de vue
sanitaire et leur passé désactivé parce
qu'ils n'ont pas fait la troisième dose
est ce que vous avez une solution à leur
apporter je vous remercie merci madame
micheline jacques
[Musique]
de questions
émilienne poumirol
est bon we say we merci maman présidente
monsieur ministres juste une question
très brève puisque les questions de fond
on évoquera de nouveau en séance
un cas particulier de personnes qui ont
fait des réactions extrêmement
importante la deuxième injection de
vaccin
direction générale j'aime tant et non
pas simplement avec une fièvre ou autres
juste après la deuxième injection et qui
ont été considérés par plusieurs
médecins en particulier au niveau de
l'hôpital et c'est le cas d'une
toulousaine qui m'a écrit encore ce
matin comme kde qu'ovide l'on est ce que
ces personnes là tout d'ailleurs comme
les gens qui sont comme ils l'ont placé
kobe dont elles sont est ce qu'ils
seront exemptés du pass vaccinale merci
madame monsieur retraça pardon
christophe-andré frassa merci monsieur
le président dans le prolongement de ce
que viennent de d'évoquer mes collègues
le comté et vogel je voudrais revenir
sur
et nos compatriotes qui ont un schéma
vaccinal complet ou incomplets mais
surtout pour ceux qui voulaient établir
un pass vaccinale
lorsqu'ils ont
contracté la maladie à l'étranger et
qu'ils ont un certificat de
rétablissement établi par une autorité
sanitaire
étrangères hors union européenne
sur le site des démarches simplifiées
à l'issue de la loi d'août et jusqu'au
mois d'octobre
il était indiqué que le certificat de
rétablissement vallée pour
l'établissement du pass sanitaires or
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on va sur le site des
démarches simplifiées il est indiqué
qu'en ne peut plus obtenir un pass annie
terre avec un certificat de
rétablissement monsieur le ministre
est-ce qu'il est prévu que pour le pass
vaccinale pour tous nos compatriotes qui
vivent à l'étranger et qui auront besoin
pour se rendre en france et pour vivre
comme il se doit à l'aune de cette
nouvelle loi comme leurs compatriotes de
france et d et d'outre-mer avec un pass
un vaste vaccinale est ce qu'il est
prévu de rétablir que certificat de
rétablissement puisse entrer dans le
cadre de l'établissement du pass
vaccinale vernis guillotin vernet
guillotin ou
oui bonjour merci monsieur le ministre
de questions rapides je suis dans une
zone frontalière je pense que vous savez
j'ai vacciner samedi matin et on a eu un
boost de primo vaccination car les
travailleurs frontaliers aujourd'hui au
luxembourg son sommet en fait de se
faire vacciner pour accéder au monde du
travail pour le 15 janvier je voulais
savoir s'il y avait des noms thaksin a
récupéré si votre gouvernement envisage
c'est envisageable ou et envisager
d'aller chercher des non vaccinés par la
suite dans le pur l'axé l'accès au monde
du travail et la deuxième chose je
reviens sur la question qui était posée
sur l'harmonisation transfrontalière
concernant le le pass vaccinale en effet
la maladie ou en tout cas la période de
rémission n'est pas considéré comme une
possibilité d'avoir un pass vaccinale
complet lorsque l'on suit la frontière
notamment au luxembourg est ce qu'il y
aurait une possibilité d'harmoniser ses
fins et autorisation de passes vaccinale
merci des deux dernières questions
madame bello romana belrhiti et après
c'est le ministre qui s'exprimait au
cours est relié la question de ma
collègue florence lassarade à laquelle
vous n'avez pas répondu monsieur le
ministre
est ce que le gouvernement entend aider
financièrement nos collectivités
territoriales dans l'achat
l'installation des purificateurs d'air
c'est une dépense supplémentaire qui
pèse encore sur les collectivités qui
ont démontré combien les invités
essentiel pour cette dans cette crise
sanitaire merci
alors très rapidement tout d'abord je
voudrais savoir quelle est la définition
du statut des non vaccinés est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a reçu qu'une
aucune injection ou avec un schéma
vaccinal incomplets ou considérés comme
nos effectifs car inférieure à 14 jours
serait-il possible d'avoir des données
affinées et plus détaillée
quelles sont les données études précises
qui justifie la vaccination des rétabli
de nombreux médecins demandent quelles
données études justifie la vaccination
des rétabli alors même que de nombreuses
études montrent une réduction drastique
du risque de formes graves de plus de 90
% chez les patients rétabli par rapport
au patient sans antécédent de primo
infection réduction pérenne dans le
temps sachant que la prévention des
formes graves et maintenant le but
reconnu de la vaccination dont l'effet
de plus est assez transitoire enfin les
certificats médicaux des décomptes de
non contre indication de la vaccination
permet-il de bénéficier du pass
vaccinale afin de lever toute ambiguïté
sur la question
merci madame eh bien merci à chacun et
chacune d'entre vous a laissé la parole
au ministre pour sa réponse ou ses
réponses
j'ai cinq minutes 4 minutes 30 à
l'horloge monsieur prison pour répondre
à 60 questions
je plaide la grâce de la commission et
me laisser l'opportunité peut-être de
déborder de quelques minutes je fais une
seule première réponse qui sera un peu
plus complète que les autres après je
serai style télégraphique c'est sur
cette question d'immunité conférée par
la vaccination j'ai fait cette cette
intervention à l'assemblée nationale ça
me semble utile de la refaire vous avez
si je globalise je suis pas
immunologiste deux types d'immunité
l'humilité qu'on appelle l'immunité
humorale qui se traduit par les
anticorps des armes qui empêche les
cellules de rentrer dans les dix russes
de rentrer dans les cellules humaines et
vous avez ce qu'on appelle l'immunité
cellulaire c'est la capacité de la
cellule a conservé dans la durée la
possibilité de fabriquer des armes
contre le virus si jamais le virus
rentrée deux types d'immunité ce qu'on
sait c'est que les vaccins arn messagers
actuelle files heures et moderna sont
moins bons en immunité une morale sur le
variant aux microbes mais reste très bon
en immunité cellulaire ça veut dire que
on est moins bon avec le vaccin pour
empêcher le virus de rentrer dans la
cellule donc pour empêcher l'infection
et la contamination
on reste très performant pour permettre
à la cellule de se battre efficacement
contre le virus une fois qu'il est
rentré pour l'empêcher de se multiplier
et de faire des formes graves c'est
pourquoi le vaccin les vaccins actuels
sont très performants pour limiter les
risque de formes graves mais il
n'empêche pas où ils empêchent - les
risques de contamination aux variants
omicron ça c'est important et ça répond
d'ailleurs une autre question qui est de
se dire pourquoi est ce que quand j'ai
un taux d'anticorps x ou y on va me
vacciner parce que votre taux
d'anticorps x ou y il ne reflète que de
votre immunité immoral combien
d'anticorps vous a vraiment donné dans
votre dans votre circulation mais ça ne
dit rien de la capacité de vos cellules
à fabriquer des armes en nombre
suffisant pour lutter contre le virus en
cas d'infection d'accord pour ça qu'on
n'avait jamais utilisé sauf pour les
immunodéprimés un taux d'anticorps pour
déterminer s'il y avait lieu ou non de
se vacciner mais demandaient les
chiffres précis je vous les donne sur le
variant omicron si j'ai été infectées et
que je ne suis pas vacciné c'est une
protection contre l'infection de 35%
elle est de 55% si j'ai été vacciné deux
doses et allait de 85 %
si j'ai eu mon rappel depuis moins de
six mois voyez déjà l'écart quand même
contre l'hospitalisation si j'ai eu le
col vide et que je ne suis pas vacciné
j'ai 80 % de risque de moins de faire un
de développer de faire une forme grave
dans les six mois 50% au-delà de six
mois de moins donc c'est une réduction
effectivement que j'ai une protection
qui est acté qui a acquise par
l'infection mais elle n'est pas totale
par contre j'ai eu mes deux doses
ma protection les de 90% dans les six
premiers mois contre l'hospitalisation
elle tombe à 70% au delà de six mois
c'est pour ça qu'on fait un rappel et
c'est pour ça qu'on réduit
progressivement le délai de rappel parce
qu'on a initialement ne savait pas au
bout de combien de temps et militer
baisserait maintenant on se rend compte
qu'au bout de trois mois ça justifie de
faire le rappel pourrait remonter tout
de suite au-dessus de 90 % de réduction
des formidables et si j'ai eu mon rappel
la réduction des hospitalisations les 2
95% des six premiers mois et dans les
six mois d'après on sait par corps au
maximum ce qu'on n'a pas le recul
suffisant monde estime qu'elle sera au
moins égal à 90%
toute la rhétorique sur vous avez
supprimé 5000 lits xterra je n'y reviens
parce que pardonnez moi je suis épuisée
d'y revenir à chaque fois d'expliquer
qu'on a pas fermé des lits
intentionnellement qui a des chambres
doubles qui sont devenues des chambres
seules parce que madame la sénatrice si
vous étiez hospitalisé ce que je ne
souhaite pas dans une chambre double
avec un malade contaminé au co vide et
que vous n'êtes pas vous mêmes
contaminées au co vide vous serez je
pense assez soulagé du fait qu'on vous
dise que la chambre double ne devient
qu'une chambre sommes sol et donc quand
vous avez vingt mille malades
aujourd'hui hospitalisé pour qu vide
dans nos hôpitaux ça fait pour un
certain nombre de cas des chambres
doubles qui deviennent des chambres
simples secoue dans un an on identifiera
comme vous avez fermé tandis mais ce qui
ne traduit pas la réalité ni les raisons
donc je prouve vous propose qu'on en
sorte de 7 cette attaque la qui était
vraiment très courante sur les nombre de
lits de réanimation de la même manière
nous les augmentons nous les avons pas
diminué 700 lits supplémentaires dans la
durée ce qui est un nombre de lits
important en plus alors qu' il faut 10 à
12 ans pour former des anesthésistes et
des réanimateurs n'est pas un ou deux
ans comme je l'entends parfois certains
candidats présidentiels le dire on ne
formait évidemment pas un médecin même
diplômée en techniques de réanimation en
un an ça prend beaucoup plus de temps
que cela sur notre activité hospitalière
on a doublé le prix des heures sup on a
doublé le rachat des congés et eu tout
le ségur je n'y reviens pas et j'y serai
tout à l'heure en vous quittant avec les
iyad par exemple dans les suites du
rapport de l'inspection générale pour
voir comment faire évoluer leur métier
leur complète pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
propose pas de compenser les pertes de
rémunération des médecins dans le
secteur public parce que les médecins du
secteur public sont salariés et que
leurs salaires ne dépend pas de
l'activité ou des actes et donc il n'y a
donc pas de perte de revenus canton des
programmes des soins à l'hôpital public
sur kovacs l'union européenne c'est le
premier continent producteur est le
premier pays le premier continent
exportateurs de vaccins l'enjeu n'est
pas mais là mais sénatrice qui me poser
la question sur la levée des brevets
l'enjeu est de savoir combien de doses
on est capable de donner dans l'urgence
avant de se dire que des pays
pardonnez-moi mais des pays qui sont en
voie de développement vont être capables
de produire par eux-mêmes dans des
usines extrêmement complexe à mettre en
place des vaccins moi je préfère qu'on
me mettre nos forces dans la bataille
pour leur livrer les vaccins et l'autre
gros enjeu on en parle peu mais il est
au moins aussi important que le don de
doses c'est comment est-ce que ces doses
sont utilisés une fois qu'elle arrive
parce que si vous n'avez pas
l'infrastructure logistique si vous
n'avez pas les personnes pour vacciner
si vous n'avez pas un système de santé
mais si vous n'avez pas ne traite que
des plans de communication sur la
vaccination ou avoir des vaccins mais
c'est compliqué de les utiliser or un
certain nombre de pays nous ont dit là
on est arrivé à saturation de ce qu'on
était capable de faire et donc on
travaille avec ces pays non seulement
leur donne des doses mon travail avec
ces pays pour leur permettre de
renforcer leurs capacités à vacciner sur
place sur la semaine une question m'a
été posée sur les tests payant sur la
semaine d'avant celle ci n'est pas
encore les chiffres sur la dernière soit
8 8 points 3 millions de tests réalisés
500000 été payant c'est à dire 7,8
millions étaient totalement pris en
charge oui les vaccins s'améliore il ya
ce qu'on appelle des boosters ils sont
capables de tenir compte des nouveaux
variants ces discussions des
laboratoires qui communiquent ce soit à
yzeure ou moderna sur les perspectives
de développer des vaccins qui serait
booster pour être aussi efficace contre
les contaminations qu'il était contre
delta avec des variants issus du au
micron s'il devait y en avoir je lui ai
répondu monsieur le sénateur dans le
débat parlementaire au président le fur
si vous avez un certificat en bonne et
due forme de contre indication à la
vaccination il ya une validation qui est
fait par l'assurance maladie qui vous
délivre un retour un document muni d'un
qr codes avec intégration dans tout
senti qu vide au même titre qu'un pass
sanitaires ou impasse vaccinale n'y a
personne n'est lésé
j'ai marqué
vax débité à nom de max débuté à
l'étranger les règles du pass sont les
mêmes que celles du des règles en
vigueur actuellement avec le pass
sanitaire ça ne changera pas avec le
pass vaccinale définir
ah oui pourquoi est ce qu'on demande aux
préfectures de pouvoir accéder aux
chiffres de redonner de side up c'est
important ça pourrait qu'on demande aux
préfectures de pouvoir accéder aux
données sidec qui vous dit si les
patients sont contaminées ou non parce
que quand vous avez des mesures
d'isolement qui sont prononcés de
quarantaine le seul moyen d'être sûr que
la quarantaine a été respecté c'est de
pouvoir vérifier le moment où le test
qui permet de sortir de la quarantaine a
été réalisée c'est le seul c'est le seul
usage qui en sera fait si vous
l'autorisez
l'autorisation parentale pour les 5 11
ans c'est le conseil d'état qui nous a
demandé à restaurer une obligation
biparentales pour cette tranche d'âge si
la représentation nationale souhaite
aller vers une simplification elle en
est évidemment libre de le proposer
c'est une demande du conseil d'état qui
a dit pour des 5 11 ans la loi n'a pas
spécifié les choses donc c'est par
défaut une des clés une obligation
biparentales la sénatrice je serai
demain en séance avec vous bon pied bon
oeil à 14h30 pour commencer l'examen du
texte concernera probablement avec mon
secrétaire d'état au gré d urgence
sanitaire à gérer mais je serai toujours
avec vous même si je ne suis pas tout le
temps dans l'hémicycle je serais plus
que par la pensée
puisque pas plus que par la pensée je le
serai aussi par le coeur voilà je serai
également aux questions au gouvernement
mercredi au sénat mais un seul un seul
être vous manque et tout est dépeuplé je
ne sais pas si je prie d'encana veut
compléter ma citation
j'ai parlé du passage éventuel en
l'autotest pour simplifier la vie des
parents dans les écoles où je ne viens
pas j'attends qu'on puisse peaufiner
tous à y réfléchir combien de faux pas
190000 pourquoi l'art pendant ce la
repentance ça permet à quelqu'un qui
était déterminé à ne pas se faire
vacciner et donc à se procurer des faux
documents de se rendre compte qu'en fait
il a fait une grosse grosse bêtise et de
pouvoir et tout simplement de pouvoir de
pouvoir de pouvoir tout simplement être
vaccinés or si l' impasse en bonne et
due forme et qui ont un certificat de
vaccination bonne et due forme qui se
présente dans un centre on va dire
monsieur vous êtes déjà vaccinées donc
il faut qu'il puisse dire en fait non
j'ai triché et j'ai pas été vaccinés
vacciner moi s'il vous plaît mon médecin
m'avait trompé ou machine à vétroz ecsta
et laon le vaccine parce que l'essentiel
c'est effectivement
de les vacciner j'ai la gorge qui est
sèche rassurez-vous au bout d'une heure
et demie c'est pour ça que je tousse
haute alors
le
merci
on est bien au sénat bon on
m'a posé la question des soignants non
vaccinés pourquoi est-ce qu'on empêche
les soignants dont acte et d'exercer
quand on pourrait mais permettrait à des
soignants cas positifs asymptomatiques
hop aussi symptomatique de travailler
ces deux de quatre exercices totalement
différent il ya l'exercice dans la durée
et l'exercice dans une situation
exceptionnelle dérogatoires où on aurait
vraiment pas de choix un soignant
positif qui sera amené à travailler
c'est la sphère de trois jours c'est
exceptionnel dans des services
particuliers est vraiment quand on n'a
pas le choix un soignant qui n'est pas
vacciné c'est tous les jours pendant la
bague ou en dehors des vagues donc c'est
différent mais madame la sénatrice
quand vous êtes sénatrice de guadeloupe
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants est
a atteint le même niveau de complétude
comme obligation vaccinale en métropole
c'est donc une très beau signal et il y
avait mille soignants ou plutôt mille
salariés d'établissements de santé pas
tellement de soignants ces salariés qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés tous se sont vus
proposer un entretien individuel en vue
d'aborder avec eux la question des
vaccinations et signe de refuser d
accompagner dans un reclassement
professionnel
625 ont accepté ce rendez-vous 300 ont
préféré partir 625 wax et et rendez vous
un tiers ont déjà été vaccinés depuis et
les autres sont toujours sur sont sur la
bonne voie pour y arriver ou sont
accompagnés donc l'obligation vaccinale
en guadeloupe se passe je dirais de
façon remarquable et je salue notamment
le directeur général de l'hôpital
monsieur côte long qui vous le savez je
reviens pas été victimes d'agressions
absolument scandaleuse la semaine
dernière j'en passe j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour passer un message à la
représentation nationale sénateur ou
député ou élus locaux ou gestionnaires
des centres ou soignants qui travaillent
dans les centres vous avez le droit non
seulement à la protection non seulement
au respect mais vous avez loin il estime
de la population pour l'engagement qui
est le vôtre pour protéger les français
c'est exactement l'inversé de ce que
montre une partie très minoritaire de la
population qui s'en prend verbalement ou
physiquement aux gens qu'il devrait
plutôt remercier
sur la question du titre pourquoi son
parle plus propagation c'est une
recommandation du conseil d'état parce
que la diffusion du virus est trop
importante au stade auquel nous parlons
est ce que le secteur privé mobiliser
oui les chiffres en attestent ils sont
très mobilisés les recommandations du
hcsp du haut conseil pour la santé
publique les masques ffp2 la
recommandation m'a été remis ce week-end
je pense que nous allons la publier ce
soir ou demain et vous verrez que c'est
une recommandation qui portent
essentiellement sur les soignants et qui
je suis je résumais l'avis du hcsp
n'irai pas vers une extension du port du
fp de y compris d'ailleurs dans le
milieu des soignants au delà des
soignants qui sont aujourd'hui
considérées comme à risque parce que
exposait des gouttelettes c'est la
recommandation du hsv le gouvernement
aura évidemment à se prononcer nous
allons discuter de cela on rendra
publique la vie vous verrez qu'on est
assez loin d'après le hcsp d'étendre le
ffp2 à d'autres catégories
professionnelles
sur la question des stocks en oxygène
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui a au moins
quinze mille patients qu'on peut prendre
en charge en ville avec aux deux
extracteurs bouteille si vous avez
entendu dire qu'on manquait d'oxygène
vous je veux bien savoir où qui quand et
comment parce que ça nous permettra de
vérifier avec eux et on en a
eu ben on regarde région paca est un peu
vague si vous me donnez un nom moi je
veux bien qu'on l'appelle parce que vous
savez des fois on appelle les gens qui
sait pas si clair que ça
sur le nombre de lits en réanimation et
à 6002 et le nombre de lits en
réanimation armée augmente au fur et à
mesure des besoins comme nous l'avons
fait au cours des vagues précédentes
je ne répondrai pas votre question
monsieur kader qui me semble très
provocatrice sur combien de morts au
rayon nous éviter en écoutant et
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale sur
le au sénat sur le vaccin obligatoire je
vous ferai pas l'injure de vous demander
monsieur le sénateur combien de morts
nous avons évité en ne suivant pas votre
grande à sion et en prenant place en
mettant en place des mesures de
couvre-feu de confinement de jauge de
limitation de circulation lors des dix
pjl précédent lors des 10 gbe pg le
précédent où les groupes socialistes ont
voté contre je crois que c'est
franchement pas hauteur du débat que
nous avons eu de cet après-midi sur la
levée des breuvages et répondu sur la
reconnaissance du certificat de
rétablissement si c'était si c'est au
sein de l'union européenne que la
contamination a été constatée par tests
biologiques alors c'est considéré comme
tel sans problème si c'est hors de
l'union européenne ça dépend de notre
capacité à le démontrer on est en train
de chercher des solutions techniques
avec des pays dans lesquels on peut
avoir plus ou moins confiance dans la
capacité de quelqu'un va réaliser une
pcr en bonne et due forme et donc c'est
cela que nous travaillons évidemment
pour simplifier la vie
français qui est vivre où évoluent à
l'étranger
et le pass vaccinale et où le passé
littéraire et le travail vous savez
qu'on avait abordé cette question les
partenaires sociaux nous ont demandé de
ne pas le mettre en place il n'y avait
pas de consensus et pas de capacité à
trouver un chemin et c'est pourquoi nous
avons opté sur le télétravail dont
l'efficacité comment je le disais en
préambule à être mesurable puisque et
nous il semble qu'il ya déjà un impact
sur la dynamique épidémique qu'on
s'était depuis quelques jours dans le
pays avec toute la prudence nécessaire
enfin du monologue madame la présidente
monsieur le président merci pour votre
écoute
si monsieur le ministre à demain alors
merci à chevigny ce ton cas de ma 14
14h30 nous allons lever la séance la
commission des affaires sociales se
réunit sa danse asrl salle de st très
dense a tout de suite et la commission
des lois à 16h30 ici sales mais
difficile voilà
pourquoi pas là parce qu'on n'est pas
sûr de voir fini à 16h30